everybody
is in cave now and they are calling us
and telling what is going on and it's
and it's awful
well we're going here to poland and then
we'll may probably go to cyprus
to my friends to to stay for when when
the bombing the hot
uh situation comes down a little bit
we're going to chirkasi to our family to
be together now in this not very safe
time in ukraine but we will
have a victory
i believe
you know
what we've just seen in those interviews
are the people who are being sacrificed
because a thug on the international
stage is taking over a country with
little if any push back from the rest of
the world one of the things i want to
add to what jesse was saying is that
um
the i have heard that the russians are
at a distinct advantage in terms of
their ability to wage uh war at night
more so than the ukrainians unless i
misunderstood you but the russians and
as much as you want them to stand her
aldo and fight these people don't have
the capability with 190 000 military and
hospitals and blood and everything else
to fight back this isn't you know some
kind of theoretical scenario these are
real life people are gonna die and in
the end what frustrates me is the the
the the the
what we've done is we've created a
dependence on russian oil europe and
germany germany was in a bind because of
their dependent on russian oil and gas
we closed down our pipelines so we're
dependent so what happens you're right
geraldo about china and russia because
russia can sell its oil to china so then
the question is what sanctions do we
have that will make a difference i don't
know but what i do know is that you
cannot
try to convince an aggressor or a thug
like this to stop he's on his way it's
he's on his way to continue to establish
the ussr as it was years ago that's his
mission hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else